welcome to the info session for the
Stanford ignite post 911 veterans 2023
program uh thank you all for joining
today
so my name is Kelsey I am the associate
director responsible for ignite programs
here at Stanford GSB I've been doing
this for about actually a little over
seven years now
um this will be my fourth ignite
veterans program to work on so you know
super excited to hopefully meet most of
you in person or in the zoom classroom
in a couple months
and let you know a little bit more about
the program today the other program
staff are my colleague Jae Ying who
works closely with me on all of the
ignite programs so the two of us are the
team that are sort of on the ground with
you
guiding you through the program
experience and supporting you as well as
the faculty throughout your time at
ignite and then our faculty director
yossi Feinberg is the he's you know the
ignite guy so he has developed all the
curriculum the assignments throughout
the program he teaches a number of
sessions and then does regular check-ins
with the small project groups throughout
the ignite program so he's a faculty
member that you'll get an opportunity to
develop a great relationship with during
ignites
ignite in a nutshell is a it's a
rigorous academic program and our goal
is to teach you the fundamentals of
business and developing and driving
innovative ideas forward
so essentially we've taken a lot of the
topics and content that are taught in
the MBA program and distilled them down
to a one-month intensive course that
will give you just enough of what you
need business education wise to be able
to launch a venture whether it's a small
business or the next billion dollar
startup or just to get more sort of
business knowledge
understanding and Acumen as you would
prepare to transition into a into a
civilian career
so to achieve this goal we bring in
about a dozen of the most senior and
experienced faculty at the GSB we're
really fortunate that in ignite we get
to work with what I am pretty confident
seeing are some of the top tier faculty
that we have this is a program that the
faculty love so we're able to get yeah
just really exceptional faculty who will
come in and teach a paired down version
of their MBA content so typically one or
two case studies that are really focused
on the entrepreneurship aspect of
whatever their topic is
um and the content is tailored
specifically to entrepreneurs and
entrepreneurs
there are sort of three components of
the act of the academic instruction uh
the first is the core business skills
these are the things like marketing and
finance and economics that you might
think of when you think business
curriculum so make sure that you have a
solid foundation and all of these key
business Concepts we'll also go into
more of the applied skills things like
teamwork and communication stuff that
isn't necessarily A Hard business skill
but is really important as you you know
if you are planning to become an
entrepreneur or move into you know
leadership roles what have you it's
never a bad thing to be you know have
developed your pitching skills
most of the curriculum you'll notice
isn't actually entrepreneurship focused
so instead of having you know a bunch of
Entrepreneurship classes it's marketing
but through the lens of Entrepreneurship
or accounting you know with a focus on
entrepreneurial skills
we will also have a couple of really
entrepreneurship focused classes so
yossi the faculty director will teach
entrepreneurship love someone come in
and talk about funding and we'll do a
series of design thinking workshops to
help with like user interviews and
developing a strong Market understanding
as an entrepreneur
in addition to the classroom instruction
there's also a significant team Venture
project component the goal of the
Venture project is for you to take what
you learn in The Faculty sessions and
then apply it in a more Hands-On
real-world way so everybody will be put
into teams usually of five or six to
work on an idea that one of the
teammates has proposed prior to the
program
so throughout the three and a half weeks
that you're in ignite you'll be doing
user research developing a business
model and developing a final pitch deck
among other assignments
to really kind of get that practice of
taking an idea from its you know
Inception to being a full-fledged
business plan
this is you know of course just an
academic project there's no funding or
anything like that but it's a great
opportunity to sort of get that
entrepreneurship experience within the
safety bubble of the academic setting
that is ignite
will also help supplement the program
with project guidance from yossi so like
I mentioned earlier every weekend he
will check in with each team and spend a
half hour talking with your team going
over past assignments answering
questions providing his guidance and
making sure that you know what next
steps you need that you're getting that
sort of more personal feedback
throughout the program
we'll also bring in a number of guest
speakers and panelists as well as a
mentor for each Venture team that are
primarily drawn from the Silicon Valley
and the GSB alumni pool
we'll have company visits with Bay Area
companies such as LinkedIn and um
you know and also some smaller
organizations in the area to talk
through sort of their career programs
the experience of and again the
experience of transitioning from a
military career into a more civilian
industry
and then at the end of the program your
project will culminate in a pitch to a
panel of professional investors and
Industry experts so that will be an
opportunity for you to get the
experience of pitching to VCS for say
your seed funding but instead of a yes
or no and a check you'll get a
significant session of feedback from
different VCS their advice their
recommendations and tools that you can
then use if you do decide to take this
or any idea forward post program
the benefits of the program at least we
hope include learning the language of
business
so even if you know you don't know
everything that there is to know about
Finance you now know the key kind of
Concepts and terms and have enough that
you know where to get started with
learning more about whatever specific
aspect of finance you need
we'll also help you develop the skills
to turn an idea into a successful
Venture so whether the project that you
work on and ignite is your idea or
someone else's whether it you know seems
like it's going to be successful post
program or not you'll have this toolkit
that you can take with you and do a mini
ignite on whatever ideas you work on in
the future whether it's a startup or a
corporate project
we'll hope to improve your teamwork
leadership and public speaking skills
and then expand your network to include
not only the cohort of you know your
peers and like-minded entrepreneurs who
go through this ignite program with you
but also close to 3 000 ignite alumni
around the world
as well as the you know mentors and
panelists and other volunteers who come
in from the Silicon Valley to support
the program
the ignite program for veterans is
offered in an online format so what this
means is that there will be interactive
sessions in Zoom these are not like
pre-recorded
um you know self-paced modules
um you'll be in a virtual classroom
every day with your fellow classmates
interacting with the professor doing
small group breakouts as well as you
know some more traditional lectures
this means that live attendance is
required we are typically able to offer
recordings on a case-by-case basis but
um it's not something that we you know
offer as sort of the standard method of
attending classes so in order to get the
full program experience it's important
that you be prepared to be in the zoom
classroom every day and really you know
engaging and interacting with the
professors and your fellow participants
will keep a super consistent schedule
with regular breaks to make sure that
you're getting to enjoy the classroom
and aren't getting any Zoom fatigue as
you sit in the classroom every day
we'll also incorporate a number of
virtual social and networking events so
our goal is for you not only to leave
with the academic content but also to
you know leave with this really strong
network of your fellow participants who
you have gotten to know during the
program
we'll also have you know a slack
workspace for you to interact with your
fellow participants as well as to work
with your program team
the program structure is you know three
and a half or so weeks so October 8th
through November 2nd during that time
you'll have class sessions from 9 A.M
till about 3 P.M every day in Zoom these
times are all Pacific by the way and in
addition to the weekday classes you'll
also have a Saturday or possibly Sunday
check in with yossi so you'll be in the
classroom 9 A.M to 3 P.M on weekdays and
then you'll have about a half hour that
you know sometime during the weekend
that you'll need to jump on a call with
Professor Feinberg
in addition to that you should plan to
spend a significant amount of time
working with your Venture team either
before or after class or on the weekends
but you know the times that are listed
here do not include the team meeting
time and all of that project work that
needs to happen in order to prepare for
the final pitches
in addition to the posted dates there is
a pre-programmed component that will
happen online in our novoid classroom
and that starts September 13th that's
primarily when you'll first get to start
interacting with your fellow
participants and also submitting Venture
ideas and sort of whittling down the
pool of venture ideas as we prepare to
form the teams on the first day of the
program
the cost of this program is twenty five
hundred dollars which is heavily
subsidized by a number of generous
alumni donors and other folks in the
gsbe community who helped us reduce the
rate to make it easier for you all to
come join us and hopefully ignite your
career
and then at the end of the program
you'll receive a certificate of
participation so there aren't any grades
or academic credit hours or you know
transferable like continuing studies
credits
it's also unfortunately not eligible for
the GI Bill
that's something we've tried it's not
available at this time but there are a
number of other funding opportunities if
that's something that you are looking
for
the application process is competitive
so we capped the program size at 50 in
order to make sure that
you're still getting those meaningful
group interactions and are having that
highly engaging interactive classroom
experience
the application deadline will be August
17th this year and the application
includes everything is included in your
online application so there are some
essay questions to answer a resume to
upload you'll have you'll request a
recommendation through that online
application portal and that
recommendation typically comes from
um a colleague or supervisor
in your career or can also come from you
know anyone else who you feel has been
sort of a professional Mentor somebody
who knows you
either in a professional capacity or is
very familiar with your entrepreneurial
Ambitions and can speak to those in a
recommendation but that recommendation
is submitted through an online form
there's no need for a like formal
letterhead signed kind of recommendation
letter
and lastly you'll be asked to submit an
online video interview this is linked
through the that same online application
portal and they'll include two video
questions
when you go to do your interview you'll
have plenty of opportunities to practice
in the interview platform before you
start your actual you know final
interview but once you do the final
interview just be aware that you only
get one shot at recording the answers to
the questions
um in an attempt to replicate the
experience of having say an in-person
interview where you're answering the
questions kind of on the Fly
we're aware that
can be a little a little more
nerve-wracking to answer those kind of
questions on on video as opposed to the
in in-person type of interview so you
know we get it it but that allows the
application or the admissions committee
to review your answers as they review
your essays and really you know review
each applicant as a holistic application
um
so with that I think that's actually it
on my presentation so I'm going to go
ahead and stop screen sharing and
welcome our panelists to come back on
camera
all right so panelists thank you so much
for joining us today I'm going to go
ahead and have you introduce yourselves
everybody here is from the 2022 ignite
veterans cohort
um if you can share your name
um a little bit about your background
and then what you have been working on
since ignite
Kathy you're first on my list so we'll
start with you great I'm Kathy Chan I
retired from the Air Force a little over
10 years ago I spent the first five
years after the military traveling
around the world settled in Hawaii
opened my own consulting firm
but I I attended ignite because I had
this I've always had this burning desire
to start
to grow something to start my own
business
and I thought to myself you know if I'm
going to do it Now's the Time uh
you know so I I joined the program
and what I will say is that it it was a
great incubator for some ideas that I
had
um which I am now you know involved in a
couple of startups and the ignite
program has been extremely helpful for
me
um in that regard all the information
that I learned is relevant and useful
I'm going back to a lot of those
resources even
um some of the people who have topic
classes are have offered their time and
have been extremely helpful but the
other thing I wanted to say is that even
if you aren't thinking of starting your
own business there are a lot of useful
lessons to learn and ignite from the
empathy portion of it that kind of helps
you understand where other people are
coming from to Game Theory to some of
the leadership strategy it's it's all
very relevant in everyday life so I
can't say enough good things about the
program
Andrew will go to you next
hello I'm Andrew border
I uh I'm a submarine officer I decided
to do the program after I was getting I
found out I was getting medically
separated from the Navy so
um
but when to ignite to think about what I
want to do next I'm still in the Navy I
actually just got my separation order so
um I've moved on yet but I had the
opportunity to return to the Naval
Academy and teach physics for the
semester while I was waiting to separate
um so that's what I've been doing since
and I will be moving to Philadelphia and
going to Penn for law school uh coming
up here so a little bit different uh go
more Professional Services then start my
own thing but maybe there will be my own
firm or something in the future
um Danny let's go to you next
all right Danny sorry Danny Goering I
just retired from the Army about uh four
months ago uh I was a civil Affairs
officer
uh here uh I'm still stationed at I'm
sorry not station anymore I live in
Washington uh near the Seattle area
I'm working on the project that we uh
we're we're doing in ignites uh
equestrills so I've just kind of taken
that on full time along with uh spending
more time with family
um yeah for my ignite experience so one
just
it was like the first time I shared with
with the team kind of what I was working
on so getting some of that immediate
feedback on the ideas that I had and
then I actually ended up using much of
the pitch deck that we built in ignite
to help me get into another accelerator
program uh with REI so I'm just really
thankful to my teammates and the program
for helping us develop that
um along with I think Kathy mentioned it
like the number of Faculty that are
willing to to work with you um off on
the side has just been incredible
um and again it it all helped me to kind
of get where I'm I'm going
um with with questions
um the other thing that I really liked
about night is that everyone that is
part of the program has either
transitioned or is in the process of
transitioning
from the military so to be with other
high performers that like are really
seeking something you know they're their
next steps
um in life
um was just really one good to
commiserate with and then to get advice
on that
great well thank you
um Jake will head to you next
yep hi everyone my name is Jake Neal
um like Andrew I'm Navy as well
um still active duty
um flying helicopters I'm currently in
San Diego I'm the last bit of my uh
contract here do my consistency tour if
any of you are familiar with that it's
on a ship now
um I guess I would just Echo a lot of
what uh Kathy and Danny and Andrew said
have
um ignite my reasons for going were
um
I'm interested in transitioning out of
the military and kind of knew that and
at the time I had a really flexible job
that allowed me to dedicate the time and
devote the time towards ignite and to be
like Danny said with uh High performers
and like-minded individuals who are
looking to do something else
um it really gave a network and exposure
to a whole different side of Academia
and professional military networking
that I hadn't experienced before so
um yeah the quality of instruction the
quality of faculty and staff the guest
speakers just a really incredible
opportunity so I can't speak Kylie
enough of it
um thank you all
um
I have a couple more questions for
um for the panelists and then we'll open
it up to questions for for the from the
attendees so if you do have any
questions uh feel free to start entering
them in the chat and or once we go to q
a um you can unmute and ask them but for
now panels have a couple more questions
for you
so Jake I think we'll start with you on
this one and then go in the opposite
order what advice do you have for new
participants that you wish you had when
you started
um advice wise I think
so coming in I really didn't have like
an adventure idea a project that I was
really yearning to expand upon a lot of
people will come into class and the last
thing they needed like Danny for example
to kind of put them over the hump was I
am going to go to ignite and then I'm
going to learn what I need and I'm going
to go forward with my idea my idea I
wanted to come in and more so learn
about the process of what it is to take
an idea develop that idea pitch it to
investors to venture capitalists and
then take that idea or service to Market
um and I think in part of that and
ignite does a really good job of pairing
you up with your group but it's easy to
kind of get scope locked in with the
group that you're assigned with I think
and so I would say if I gave myself
advice it would be to maybe reach out
more be more proactive with my other
classmates because while the four people
that I was with we are became very close
over the course of the class I have no
doubt that those same relationships
could have been fostered if I would have
just been maybe more proactive with
getting to know other classmates as well
Daniel will go to your next
I will I'll say that uh at the very
start of the program I was really
vacillating on the idea on whether or
not I wanted to put my idea forward
um into you know are tossing it in for
for votes whether or not it would be
picked up I was just kind of worried
about rejection I was worried about
I don't know proprietary stuff all this
all the stuff that like there's really
no concern for it so I would say if any
of you have an idea that you're kind of
like wondering you know should I kind of
put it through the night process I would
say go for it you know worst case
scenario is that your idea doesn't get
picked up but at least you put it out
there and you get feedback on it
um immediately
and then Andrew we'll see you next
uh so Jake stole it I was gonna say I
was going to say
um talk to your classmates because we
get really close as a group and with
some other people but um yeah we're all
here for the same thing going through
transition but building off what Danny
said
um putting yourself out there with your
ideas I think
I was nervous for different reason
coming in I was worried because I didn't
have a adventure idea
um that I I think that's okay and I
don't think it's a prerequisite for uh
participating in the program and I
actually got the opportunity to work on
Danny's idea
um which was uh I didn't expect to do
something like what we were doing but I
learned so much and um I think something
I really like about the program is
getting to kind of take idea to uh
business plan just learning about
entrepreneurship and um I I appreciate
that you don't need to bring the idea to
get that experience
right now I'm Kathy
I guess the only thing I would add is if
I could have done it differently I would
have done ignite earlier when I looked
at the program description
years ago I read it and I said well I
don't know you know if I'm a good fit
for this program
um and and then ultimately I ended up
applying and doing it and
um I do wish I'd done it earlier I guess
that's the only thing I agree with
everybody else what they what they said
about bringing your ideas to the table
um networking with your other classmates
all of that is is great advice I guess
the one other thing I would say is as I
was
um when we were in ignite in the very
beginning when we were deciding or
voting or trying to put our names in for
different Venture ideas you know I
started off thinking
um oh one of my most interested in what
is the most interesting to me but what I
ultimately ended up
um Team wise was I thought to myself
well where can I contribute the most
where do I have the most background
where I can contribute to this team so
that's just something I put out there as
well
um and what was the live online learning
format like for you as a participant
um I think this time will start in the
Middle with Danny
so I I will say like I was a little
concerned about that because I know that
uh ignites for veterans used to be in
person let's just say oh you know what
am I missing out on
um but there were a lot of luxuries that
also came up live on learning uh
platform that I did get to be home every
every night with my family instead of
you know being off for for three weeks
um down in San Francisco
um it was really interactive I wasn't
expecting it to be as
as good as and as engaging as it is
because I have done other online modules
before and it just seems you can kind of
get lost in uh
in the process of everything else
um where it's just lecture after lecture
and then there's really no feedback
that's given but I'd say the way ignite
does it with with breakout section
sessions you do work with other folks
outside of your own team to go over uh
lesson reviews I I would say I really
appreciated that and then the number of
times that you get feedback from staff
is incredible not only with your your
project but again with other things that
you're submitting
okay thank you
um Jake we'll go to you next
yep I would uh Echo the same thing I
think
um if I remember correctly the way it
was structured was the morning was the
lectures and then the afternoon was when
you're with your groups so that really
helped break it up where
I'll be honest like there were some
things that I was just more
um interested in in terms of learning I
mean uh the communications courses like
that one sticks out and whereas the more
you know econometrics and data-driven
stuff not really in my wheelhouse but
the way to like you do such a good job
of breaking it up with the afternoon
sessions because you're back with your
team and then uh yes the days I think
you mentioned it's like six hours but
um I didn't ever feel like I had Zoom
fatigue by any means and that's you know
after having all of us gone through the
covet era of being on Zoom all the time
with the way that it's broken up even if
you feel like hey maybe I'm not super
interested in this particular lecture I
know that the lecture tomorrow and the
case study that I'm going to read
tonight is going to pique my interest
and then the guest speakers as well like
each week there was a guest speaker that
I was excited to hear from that I was
like oh man you know I can't wait until
we get to that lecture because it's also
going to be exciting so there was always
like something that kept you engaged
um bottom line yeah
uh Kathy we'll go to you next
I was surprised how engaging and
immersive it was and a lot of that has
to do with Kelsey and the staff they did
a fantastic job I I can't even imagine
how hard it is to manage all those
breakout rooms and all those Logistics
but they just did a fabulous job and I'm
not like really one for icebreakers but
they did do a really good job with the
icebreakers and if if you're gonna do an
icebreaker you know they definitely did
a fantastic job with that so hats off to
you guys
thank you
um Andrew we'll finish up with you I I
don't have much to add the liberal use
of breakout rooms made it
um you know pretty interactive it didn't
feel like I was just watching online
lectures
um well thank you
um Andrew I think we'll start with you
for one last question
um do you have any advice on how to
balance the demands of ignite
um you know either I guess how to
balance the demands of ignite and your
other obligations career family the team
project Etc
that so I was very fortunate that I
didn't have uh much to balance
career-wise I was in a transition period
where I I really just got to focus on
um ignite so it was just ignite and
family for me
um so when I was on the East Coast so
for me it was like 12 to six so
um I was able to do kind of at home and
family stuff in the morning and then
take care of dinner and my wife's very
supportive for the kind of afternoon
period when I was really involved with
Ignite and it helped it's only you know
it's a month
um kind of Sprint so
being able to put off some of that
responsibility or not have that
responsibility juggling definitely
helped me I think the other panelists
can probably talk about balancing career
a little bit better
thank you
um Kathy will go to you next
I would just say that it is very time
consuming if you are
um really immersing yourself in the
experience which I highly recommend that
you do it's not just the time online
with the classes but also there's a lot
of time that you spend meeting with your
groups and reading the material and just
um you know if you have any kind of idea
that you're running through the template
as you're going through the program all
that time all that takes a lot of time
so I guess my only advice would be to to
kind of
um take care of everything that you can
ahead of time before the program so if
you have any projects that you've been
waiting to do that maybe do during the
time that you're in ignite take care of
that stuff first the other thing I would
say is maybe share with your boss
co-workers that you're in the program so
that they have a little more
understanding of what your challenges
are and maybe give you a little bit of a
pass during the month that you're that
you're in the program
um Jake will go to you next
yeah so I kind of had a similar uh setup
as Andrew single east coast hours so
um pretty flexible
um I think kind of the key to success
would be communication like uh Kathy was
saying like whether it's with your boss
or with the faculty and staff
um and specifically with your teammates
when you get teamed up with your Venture
team I know for the Saturdays
um we had one of our classmates Zoomed
In from a wedding rehearsal and like we
had people coming and going from various
things but we all made it work we were
just communicated with one another on
slack or text to coordinate those events
and the faculty worked around it pretty
well so I would just say communication
is probably key with the time management
piece
Benny will finish up with you
so I was planned retirement um it just
lined up with my 180 day period where
you could do Progressive pby so I just
broke my permissive TD wild since I know
I was staying local uh in five day
increments uh taking advantage of like a
full month of not having to report into
work
um which
was really really nice I know Andrew
without with our team as well like we
kind of like laid out all the
assignments that we had to do for our
project and then we had one gal who and
she was working full-time and going TDY
all the time so she was kind of like the
first one to kind of pick which which
which project or I'm sorry
which assignment she wants to take lead
on you know so she's still got the same
experience but
um it worked out better for
deconflicting things when she was going
to be traveling or when she knew that
she was gonna have late nights at work
well
um thank you all uh at this point I'd
love to open it up to questions from
everyone else so if you have a question
that you'd like to ask either the
panelists or myself feel free to
type that in the chat or you can unmute
and ask your question
hey good afternoon
um thank you guys for your time this is
awesome
um my first question is um
regarding the entrepreneurial State uh
it sounded like Jake and Andrew at a
different place than Danny was
um how did you communicate that to the
program given that you know Danny sounds
like you got a an idea you wanted to
push forward on and Jake and Andrew
sound more like you're just trying to
learn the steps was that communicated in
the
um uh when you were applying or was that
communicate when you're already in the
program
uh Matt I think that's a great question
because that's something that I was kind
of nervous about looking at the program
description
um for me it was in the application kind
of expressing uh a curiosity and like I
was thinking about
um I was writing business school
applications at the time so I I took
some of that content the application's
not very long so you know more just the
ideas and um I mean I was honest like I
said I'm I'm interested I'm going
through a transition
um what I'm trying to learn was you know
written maybe a little bit cleaner but
that was the idea that I came with
and then Danny I guess I guess I I don't
think I even wrote about Quest trails at
all in my application because it was one
of those things where I was like really
unsure of it I thought it might be just
more of like a part-time hobby thing uh
going forward I wasn't really sure like
what my commitment was going to be at
the time of the application
um
but then as a as the program got closer
or certain during I realized kind of
wanted to go a little more uh full time
with it I don't think I mentioned it in
the
in the application just because I was
also kind of thinking like you know
go on Stanford ignites I heard great
things about it um and that's really
just for startups but for those who are
just wanting to be innovators with
inside of an organization
so I was just kind of I left my
application very much as as Andrew was
mentioning like staying just more
inquisitive and wanting to learn rather
than
put something through an incubator
process
it will also add that you know from the
staff and missions committee side
it's not a strike against you as an
applicant at all if you don't have an
idea that is already in mind
we typically expect to have a cohort
where there's some people who have an
idea that they're really excited about
may already be working on
um you know people may be bringing in
you know already existing like early
stage startups or small businesses
um so the goal is to have kind of a mix
of some of those folks and then also
people who are not yet at that stage and
don't necessarily have a clear vision of
what their next step is and are using
ignite to kind of figure out what that
next step should be
and
great thank you and then if I can ask
one more question
um after the program ended can you uh
can the panel talk to I guess what
resources are available to you both
within Stanford and then the network
that you kind of built out both from
um alumni and then also the um Stat or
the the
academic staff at Stanford
I'll go I'll go first um I can't
remember when I hit UCF Kelsey if it was
during the program it was right after
the program
but I I reached out to him because I had
a
it was an interview for Rei's
accelerated program
um for for new Ventures I was just super
nervous about it and I and I thought I
learned enough from ignite so you know
kind of like pitch everything
um but I will say like having him give
up 30 minutes of his time just to focus
on any of your process
um even went online and did some
research for me as far as like what's he
thought
um their angle was more or less for
having this program was was really
enlightening and I will say I modified a
lot of what I said in that interview
just based on his feedback and I got
picked up so I I owe him a lot of
credits and then
um Matt Abrams I think he was our
Communications instructor one I love
listening to his podcast when I get get
a chance
um but he was also really really good
about like taking the extra time
because I got midnight um I sent him
something a link to a picture I was
doing and he gave me feedback within 30
minutes before he went to bed so
again this is a program that I know
isn't really
punting much at Stanford I mean it's
it's so highly discounted already but
that these faculty members just care so
much about
like what you're doing and what you've
done let's give up their time is is
pretty impressive
I have also reached out to faculty
members
um I reached out to her fall choir
who did our legal section because I
wanted to talk about some copyright
issues I need some startup type um
things that he's an expert in and he is
uh being very generous with his time and
meeting with me
the you know it's been mentioned before
but you also have the ignite your own
cohort and then all the other igniters
um the people who are guest speakers for
the programs have also offered to
um to give of their time
um and and there are some really you
know impressive people who came in to to
talk with our class
um including like the CEO of CrossFit
and
um you know keep designs all those
people and you know during their I
haven't I haven't tested it yet but they
said during their you know during the
presentations hey hit me up on LinkedIn
you know if you have questions
um I think Kelsey can probably attest to
the fact that
um the the faculty and um and guest
speakers are you know just very
supportive in addition to the the
mentors who are assigned here to your um
group
and then I would just add real quick I
don't know if it was by Design but um in
our Venture groups there's four of us
and we all happen to be junior officers
so kind of at the point of transitioning
out and since ignite was over we've got
our group text and um there were two
army officers and then two Navy and uh
since then they've all kind of like each
person has either gone through the
transition or is like very nearly in
that point of transitioning out and uh
prior to ignite I was just woefully
unprepared for what resources were
available and having so many people that
were going through that process it was
like flooded with information I mean I I
learned as much of that process as I did
about entrepreneurship just from ignite
so I don't think there can be enough
said about that
great thank you very much
hey guys thanks for taking time to do
this
I had a question uh really I guess for
all of you but when you when you guys
talk about the network and being able to
interact with other members of of the
ignite cohort or the whole class how big
were your classes and then I guess for
Kelsey how big are the classes usually I
saw that it was capped at 50 but do you
usually get close to that
um we you know it varies year to year
um
for I guess those of you for 2022 I
believe we were at 25 or so
um participants
um typically it's in kind of the 25 to
40 range
so usually that means we then have five
or six Venture project teams that folks
are broken up into
so it's not quite enough I guess
depending on which version of Zoom you
use it's always small enough to fit
um on one screen
that's sort of the the goal um yeah I
would imagine
somewhere in the 30 to 40 range
okay thanks and a quick one for Danny
you you mentioned how you pitched your
your project which I I went and looked
at well while everybody was talking
looks awesome by the way
um but you pitched that and then you
ended up on an REI accelerated track
where they were trying to pick up
projects was that through this or
through a connection there or you had
just started pitching it elsewhere at
that time
divine intervention like everything just
kind of like lined up with my exit
timeline uh from the military so it kind
of happened and then I found out about
the accelerator program and I was able
to
accelerator program for REI was like
January through April so the timing just
worked out
um I found out about my own LinkedIn is
a tool that I never was hun really
um so I started reaching out retirement
stage so I don't know oh well verse you
are on it but we actually had a class
kind of unlinked not a class but
um
some folks in the c-suite of LinkedIn
came in and just kind of like
talk to us about about the the using
LinkedIn um more for networking which is
super helpful too
okay thanks
yeah
a question that people commonly ask is
about intellectual property and ignite
so one just throw that out there that if
you bring an idea into ignite there's no
IP change as a result of going through
the ignite program so Stanford and
ignite don't gain any shares of
ownership of any of the ideas in ignite
and if you have a project team working
on your idea it is still 100 yours at
the end of the program unless you and
your team decide to come up with some
alternate agreement
or any other
does anyone else have any questions that
we can answer
hey good evening everyone thanks Kelsey
and all panelists for uh all your
comments here tonight this has been
super helpful uh you can tell that
you're very uh selective and uh
intentional with selecting the uh
participants and I'd just be interested
to hear from some of the previous uh
participants the panelists on the the
diversity of the group both in terms of
uh with respect to demographics service
background educational background and
how that fed into the entire experience
yeah
I said I think that's an interesting
question uh I mean for me I was a JG
gone career program
um 2002 Kathy's would have been retired
for you know 10 years Danny uh I don't
remember we never really talked about it
but I think you're lieutenant colonel
um or we talked about it but we didn't
no we dropped I don't know we just
for friendly but uh sorry that was
um it was a wide range of
um interest in business uh we had Army
Navy we had a Coast Guard officer in our
group
um so just I don't know I don't think it
checked checked all those kind of boxes
for interesting backgrounds
I don't want to say don't sweats the
application process but uh
I think the selection process I like
just having the application kind of
we've done a lot of folks from
um applying
so I I don't know what the percentage
rate is Kelsey as far as like getting in
but clearly like you're interested in
the program you've served in the
military which
I mean now that I've now that I've been
on the military working with people that
aren't in the military it's just amazing
like
to me like the things that are just
innates and beat into you yeah
throughout your your years of service
regardless of how long you serve are
things that like senior folks in
different businesses like aren't even
thinking about like as far as like doing
rehearsals and and just doing like basic
checks before running in events
um so I think vegan night program knows
that and they recognize that which is
why they have this special subsect of
the ignite program so by all means like
put your time into the application but
if you're worried about
what selection I guess Kelsey probably
can talk more about like what the rates
are for selection but
right I think I I sweated it a little
too much where I spent like weeks on the
application
um and not saying that I didn't need to
put in all that effort but
um it probably wasn't as I didn't need
to pray over it as much as I I did is
that fair Kelsey
I cannot tell us the the secrets that's
probably uh fair I can't share specific
um acceptance rates or anything like
that but
Danny's absolutely correct that
um the that this tends to be a pretty
self-selecting
um group and in gen like it's pretty
rare that we get applicants who are just
not
qualified for ignite
um the yeah the military veterans
program in particular the people who
apply I'm always amazed at how
impressive of a group um this is and how
impressive of a group of participants I
then get to work with
and then with that it's like because
people are either paying or they're on
scholarship through like the good
foundation or Johnny Mac like everyone
is putting an effort so I didn't
experience it in my group and I don't
think anyone else had it in a group But
like everyone is putting their full
effort in snake night program regardless
of uh the requirements that work
so you can count on having good
teammates and good peers
um as you go through the program
uh we're just about out of time so I'd
like to thank you um you all for joining
us especially um thank you panelists for
um coming on today and talking about
your experience um you know that I can
only talk so much from the staff side um
so appreciate you sharing the you know
the actual experience of going through
the program
um if there are any questions that come
up later in the application process you
know feel free to reach out I'm always
happy to answer questions jump on a
quick call support
um you and your application process
however I can and hopefully I'll see
applications from you all by
um the August 17th deadline and for
totally meeting you in the zoom
classroom in a couple of months
so thank you all again and have a good
rest of your evening